(sirènes d'alarme)
(explosion)
- Quand les Russes envahissent
l'Ukraine dans la nuit
du 24 février, Mélanie Joly
est chez elle à Montréal
avec son conjoint.
MÉLANIE JOLY, ministre,
Affaires étrangères du Canada
- Je me sentais tellement
privilégiée d'être de l'autre
bord de l'Atlantique, d'être
chez nous, puis de serrer
mon chum. Puis là, ce qui
s'est passé, c'est qu'à 3 h 30
du matin, on m'a appelée
puis on m'a dit : "On a perdu
la connexion satellite n n n'est
pas capable de voir, d'avoir
accès à toute l'information
à savoir où lesleleleles sont
lancés. Donc c'est plus
sécuritaire de quitter."
- La premièreioioioion que
la ministre prend en temps
de guerre, c'est d'ordonner
aux diplomananananadiens
de quitter l'Ukraine. Elle doit
ensuite proposer des sanctions
à impàààà la Russie.
- Nous imposons des nouvelles
sanctions visant toutes
les s s s s banques russes.
De faire en sorte de mettre
la pression sur Poutine et
que le peuple russe manifeste
son mécontentement.
- La puissance militaire
et économique du Canada est
marginale. On n'a pas beaucoup
de moyens pour aider l'Ukraine
à gagner la guerre ou à faire
vraiment mal à la Russie avec
des sanctions. Alors, il nous
reste les pressions politiques.
Mais Mélanie Joly a rompu
ses relations diplomatiques
avec son homologue russe,
Sergueï Lavrov, pourquoi?
- Parce que erererererre-là,
avant d'arriver à une solution
diplomatique, va se gagner
sur le terrain. Et les Russes,
présennenenenene répondent que
par la force. Et donc, c'est
pour ça que le Canada on était
un des premiers pays à pousser
le p p p p pays pour envoyer
de l'artillerie lourde.
- C'est ça, c'est exactement ça.
(rires) a a a a a a dix jours, e
rencontrait à Ottawa
l'ambassadrice du Canada
en Ukraine pour planifier
une visite à Kiev et
la réouverture de l'ambassade.
- Qu'est-ce que tu entends
du terrain
LARISA GALADZA, ambassadrice,
Canada en Ukraine
- De Kiev j'entends que chaque
jour, le normal est en train
d'être rétabli; les magasins,
les salons de beauté,
les ambassades, les autres
ambassades, ils sont tous là.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Quand elle est au pays,
la cheffe de la diplomatie
canadienne revient chez elle
aussi souvent que possible.
-  g g g g g g grand besoin
d'avoir un nid puis que
les choses soient organisées.
Maintenant, c'est gérer
le stress, gérer l'anxiété, m me
me suis présentée à la mairie
à l'époque puis je faisais de
l'anxiété, je comprenais pas
qu'est-ce qui se passait.isisise
j'ai besoin d'aller courir, je
le sais que j'ai besoin aussi de
m'amuser, de pouvoir décrocher
Si vous êtes à Cuba
ou si vous avez de la famille,
ou des proches, dans le fond,
à Cuba, s'il vous plaî
appelez ce numéro-là.
- La ministre réagit ici
à la nouvelle d'une explosion
dans un hôtel à la Havane. Cela
fait partie de son mandat, de
gérer les services consulaires
quand survient une tragédie,
une catastrophe naturelle
ou un conflit armé.
- J'ai passé, au début de
la semaine, j'avais besoin de
rendez-vous pour la biométrie
pour ma grand-mère et d'
membres de la famille.
Pendant trois jours,
je regardais à tous
les 30 minutes et il y avait
absolument rien de disponible.
- Depuis deux mois, on les a
vus, des dizaines de milliers
de réfugiés sont allés cogner
aux portes des ambassades du
Canada dans les pays voisins
de l'Ukraine. Des portes souvent
fermées, dans tous les sens
du terme. Comment est-ce que
la ministre réagit quand e
voit son propre ministère ne pas
être à la hauteur des besoins?
- J'étais extrêmement fâchée.
Bien, c'est pour ça que j'ai
pae,e,e,e,e,e,e,e,e, j'ai dit :
c'est inacceptable. Écoutez,
on le savait qu'il allait
y avoir plusieurs millions
d'Ukrainiens.
♪ ♪ ♪
C'est parti.
Comment ça va?
Oui merci!
TANIA BÉLISLE, dir. politiques,
cabinet min. Affaires étrangères
- La première cho
de la journée, c'est encore
toute la question du droit
à l'avortement.
Beaucoup de tirs
à Lviv.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Il y a eu des frappes hier
à Lviv et il y en a eu encore
sur Kiev.
Bonjo
comment ça va!
Bien moi, ce que
je veux pousser, c'est
la reconstruction.
-  e e e e e e e e e entourée
de femmes; une sous-ministre,
une cheffe de cabinet,
une cheffe adjointe,
une directrice des politiques,cs
et plusieurs conseillères
politiques.
- Dans le domaine du déminage,
le département est en train dese
que vous êtes au courant,
mais c'est la sensibilisation
aux risques qui est primordial
en ce moment.
Ce serait la toute première
fois de l'histoire qu'autant
de femmes de pouvoir participent
à la gest
Mélanie Joly dit qu'elle
collabore très étroitement avec
ses homologues de la Grande-
Bretagne et de l'Allemagne,
toeseseseseseseseseseses aux
Affaires étrangères. Est-ce
que ces femmes changent vraimenn
donne au conflit en Ukraine?
- Certainement, on pense pas
comme les hommes, mais en quoi
c'est différent? C'est le niveau
d'empathie et de sensibilité
par rapport à la réalité
des femmes et des enfants.
- Ces images d'enfants et de
mamans qui fuient les bombes
bouleversent la ministre Joly.
Peut-être encore plus parce
qu'elle désire fonder une
famille. La politicienne qui
a 43 ans a failli refuser
sa nomination aux Affaires
- J'étais pas convaincue que
c'était le temps pour moi de
devenir ministre des Affaires
étrangères parce que je voulaiss
préoccupée que le fait de
voyager autant m'empêcherait
de devenir maman.
- La ministre parleveveveveveves
de fécondation in vitro.
Une démarche difficile, surtout
s'il faut la conjuguer avec de
nombreux voyages et une gestion.
Mélanie Joly croit-elle toujours
pouvoir gérer une guerre
tout en devenant maman?
- Je vais essayer de fairedededt
des années qu'un ministre
des Affaires étrangères a pas
géré une guerre. Il y a jamais
eu de ministre des Affaires
étrangères qui ont... une mère,
dans le fond, qui a un jeune
enfant. Il y a des premières
à tout!
♪♪♪♪♪♪♪♪♪